دكتوره ايمان اليوم امام كل هذه المعطيات
وشفنا كمان المخرج القانوني له بدنا نعرف
كيف صحه زوجك الان وضعه الان في المستشفى
وماذا تطالبون بعد هذا الاعتداء الوحشي من
قبل الكلب
طبعا الوضع سيء ان حال نفسيه للولد ابني
عشان كان معاه في الحادث الوضع حرج جدا
برضه ايضا تم استدعائه في النيابه للادلاء
باقواله طبعا يعني النيابه كانوا ناس
محترمين جدا وانا بشكر النيابه وتعاونهم
معانا وتقبلهم لظروفنا لكن
الحدث نفسه اثره على الولد كان طبعا قاسي
جدا نفسيا
فاحنا الاسره بتعاني من حاجات كثيره جدا
بغض النظر عن الحاله الصحيه لجزء اللي
حرجها نتمنى له الف سلامه نتمنى يطلع
بالسلامه شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معانا
وروايه هذه التفاصيل عبر الهاتف من
القاهره زوجه الضحيه التي تعرض لهجوم كلب
مفترس الدكتوره ايمان عبد المحسن ونشكر
كذلك على هذه الاضاحات المحامي بالنقد
المستشار محمد طاهر شكرا لكما